vladimir putin
i don't know if you have heard of him
he's the president of russia but he's
also uh judoka yes have you gotten a
chance to uh see him do judo what do you
think about his judo if you were to and
so i'm actually really good friends with
the the russian federation uh
the the guy in charge is izio gamba he's
an italian he's a mastermind behind
their success of the 2012 and 2016
olympic teams
2020 he suffered from leukemia blood
cancer so he wasn't part of their 2020
program but he was part of 2012 2016.
that whole national the olympic team in
2012 came to our studio
and
lived here for a month in boston they
went to school in boston i brought them
to my house they had three olympic
champions
um
they oh my god
they all came and lived here in boston
for a month they wanted to be part of
like experience america type program so
i've seen all of them with putin in
russia
at their national training center
working out with them and taking falls
and doing judo with him so
you know it's hard when you're older to
move in judo i mean i was at a high
level and i'm you know now 51.
it's hard for me to move like i used to
so at his age he's got to be what 60
between 62 65-ish
i mean it moves really well for somebody
that's that age
you know and probably hasn't done very
much judo for the last however many
years right so that tells you he at one
point he had to be a really good year
player yeah he put in a lot of work at
some point to develop the technique you
can tell when a great judo player even
if they haven't practiced it
even if they're up there in age
like just the way they move right the
way they're going for say nagi the way
they go for a particular throw
the way they do foot sweeps and all that
kind of stuff you could just tell he's
uh he's good at judo and that's kind of
fascinating
um
it's fascinating to see political
leaders i've gotten to interact with
quite a few
for whom judo
was a formative experience in their life
and that's so interesting that for a lot
of people judo was played a big part in
their life early development it's
similar to like uh if you served in the
military
there's just something about judo it's
the um as a martial art it's not just
the technique so yes
there's something about gaining
confidence through becoming aware of
what like your body can do
the sort of uh the artistry and the
skill of it also the power being able to
dominate another human being with
technique but also like the um
i don't know the formality the
discipline of just
uh honoring the tradition of it so all
of that mixed together somehow creates
memories it creates memories that kind
of define you as a human being and you
carry that forward throughout your life
and i've just been surprised to know how
many powerful people internationally
have
uh
like in their heart in their who they
are judo for sure
it makes you the human being that you
are it really does like it it becomes a
fabric of if peop the people that stick
with it right that stay with it and it
because it
i i mean it teaches you so many lessons
it's so memorable because of what you
talked about the tradition
um but it's also
you grow with other people you know and
you learn from other people and you
experience things with other people it's
it's such a hands-on sport
that um
it's very memorable and
people love it so much like
right now at my dojo we have like four
generations like somebody that judo with
my dad
you know had a kid who who trained with
me who loved you know judo so much had a
kid that kid was you know now in his 20s
who did judo and now has a kid who's two
or three or four that's coming to my
toddler program at my school like we're
talking four generations and they all
love the experience so much and what it
did for them in their lives that they
wanted the next generation to also
experience the same thing
you